hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
hepatitis e the new challenges of a
peculiar viral hepatitis
i am jennifer woods of labruz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by diasoren
to learn more visit diasoren.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
valentina switcher phd
associate professor of virology at the
department of experimental medicine and
surgery
university of rome tour vergata italy
and romina salpini phd
assistant professor at the chair of
virology department of experimental
medicine university of rome tour vergata
dr svicher and dr salpini you may now
begin your presentation
thank you so much for your kind
introduction it's a pleasure for me to
have
this presentation today
episode is e-virus hev
is a peculiar and fascinating virus
it was recently discovered indeed
it was discovered during the 80s
in particular in the setting of an
outbreak of
hepatitis broke out in soldiers during
the soviet occupation
of afghanistan hev
is usually recognized as a naked
virus with a positive sense rna
genome amazingly different
studies have found that hev
can exist either in the form of
a naked or enveloped viral
particles or too devoid of the classical
surface glycoproteins
these envelope the viral particles are
fully infectious and can establish
new rounds of replication
in particular a careful examination of
hev replication cycle has
has shown that the infected hepatocytes
can release envelope viral particles
and the fate of these envelope the viral
particles
depends on whether they enter the bile
ducts
or the blood stream in particular
viral particles entering the bile ducts
lose the envelope due to the detergent
activity of the bile source so
these viral particles become naked
enter the gastrointestinal tract and
are released through feces
a different phase fate is observed
for viral particles entering the
bloodstream
indeed these viral particles don't
lose the lipid derive the membrane
they remain enveloped and this envelope
plays an important role indeed
it allows heavy protection from
neutralizing antibodies so
these enveloped viral particles play
an important pathogenetic role since
they
allow hev dissemination
in different body compartments playing
a pivotal role in the onset of
hev-related
extropathic manifestations
hev is an rna virus so it is
characterized by
a high degree of genetic variability
that has allowed the virus to
differentiate into
different genotypes in particular
so far eight genotypes have been
identified characterized by a very large
host spectrum among them four
can infect humans in particular
it has been estimated that hev
ancestor has spilled over from
animals to humans around 1 000
years ago and then it has diversified
in genotype 1 and 2 and genotype
3 and 4. in particular genotype 1
and 2 are characterized by henos
spectrum restricted to humans
conversely genotype 3 and 4
have enough spectrum involving not only
humans but also
animals highlighting the existence of
a large animal reservoir that
plays an important role for the
dissemination
of the virus this slide
reports the geographic distribution
of hev genotypes as you can see
the distribution the circulation of
genotype 1 and 2 is frequent
in india middle east africa
and mexico conversely genotype 3
is ubiquitous and it is responsible
of the majority of cases of hev
infection
in europe or in the americas
while the circulation of genotype 4
is more restricted particularly to china
or more in general in
western pacific countries
furthermore the process of hev
genetic diversification is still ongoing
and indeed has shown in this recent
study
genotype 3 has been further diversified
into a large variety of the other
genotypes
with the different geographic
distribution
how is hev transmitted hev
can be transmitted by a very large
variety of roots in particular the
waterborne transmission and the zoonotic
transmission are considered the
classical routes
for acquiring heavy infection
waterborne transmission is typical of
genotype
one and two it is caused by drinking
water
contaminated by human feces infected
with
genotype one and two however it can
not be excluded the contamination
of drinking water by animal feces
infected with the genotype three and
four
faster more among epocities
viruses hev is the only one
that can be transmitted zoonotically
in particular zoonotic transmission is
typical of genotype 3 and 4.
it is caused by direct or
indirect contact with an infected
animal but most importantly it can be
caused
by the consumption of a contaminated
food and in particular the consumption
of a raw or or undercooked the meats
of those wines boars deers and
sheep plays an important role for the
transmission
of hev infection
furthermore it has been also postulated
that
hev can be transmitted by the
consumption of
shellfish or by the consumption of
vegetables or red fruits
irrigated by contaminated water
and you can see in this slide the very
high percentage of the muscles
positive to hev
however beyond the waterborne
or xonotic transmission hev can be
also transmitted parentally in
particular
by blood or blood component
products in particular these
different studies worldwide have
found that the proportion
of blood donors with an acute hev
infection at the time of blood donation
is not negligible there's a substantial
proportion of blood donors
positive to hev infection
in some european countries this
proportion is particularly high such as
in the netherlands furthermore
has supported by this study
the duration of acute hev infection
can be particularly long and can last
more than three months increasing the
probability of
h ev transmission
parental hev transmission
can be asymptomatic however
in immune suppress the patient's
parenteral hev
transmission can be associated with
an increasing risk to develop a chronic
heavy infection furthermore
in individuals with an underlying
chronic
liver disease parental heb
transmission can cause fatal
acute on chronic liver failure
for this reason the scientific community
is debating the importance to introduce
hev screening in the setting of blood
donation
and some countries particular some
european countries have already
introduced
such a screening in blood donors
beyond parental transmission hev
can be transmitted also vertically
in particular this recent mess analysis
has shown a quite high proportion
of vertical transmission in pregnant
women who acquired the hev
infection in particular the risk
of hev vertical transmission was around
37
as we discussed also later vertical
hev transmission can be associated
with low weight at birth with premature
delivery but also it can be also
associated
with stillbirth or intrauterine
abortion finally there's also
increasing evidence that hev can be
transmitted by solid organ
transplantation
in particular by liver transplantation
as expected since hev he is an
apothotropic virus
however there's also the evidence that
hev can be transmitted in the setting
of other solid organ transplantations
such as kidney graft
we know that the transplanted patients
must
receive immune suppressive agents
to reduce the risk of organ rejection
but this condition of immune suppression
can increase the risk to develop chronic
infection finally
there's the evidence that hev
could be transmitted sexually and in
particular
i would like to share with you this
recent study
published on journal of hepatology this
study has
shown hev detection in a seminal
fluid from individuals with a chronic
hev
infection this study has two interesting
findings in particular the former is
that
the shedding of hev in seminal fluid
can be particularly long in particular
it can last up to nine months
this the letter is that the authors
found a
genetic compartmentalization
implying that viral species detected in
seminal fluids
are genetically distinct from those
observed
circulating in the bloodstream
and these suggest a potential
role for testes has a niche
has a reservoir for hev
replication so the large variety of
routes for requiring hev infection
strongly supports the importance to set
up
a proper inadequate hev screening
for a prompt management of the hev
infected patients at risk to develop
severe clinical manifestations
and so what about the pathogenetic
implication of
hev hev is
usually considered a non-cytopathic
virus and the extent
of immune the extent of liver damage
usually depends on the strength of
immune responses
in particular acute hev infection can
run asymptomatically in the majority of
hev-infected
patients in individuals developing
hepatitis the classical symptoms are
vomiting nausea jaundice and also flares
in transaminases
mortality rate is less than one percent
however a completely different scenario
is observed in individuals with
an underlying chronic liver disease
in these patients an acute heb
infection can cause an acute on
chronic hepatitis that can lead to
feminine hepatitis and decompensated
cirrhosis and here we have a mortality
rate
of around 70 percent
a critical aspect is represented by the
fact
that these hev-related acute on chronic
hepatitis
is often unexplained remained
unrecognized or even more misdiagnosed
has for instance a drug induced the
liver
injury so this highlights
an important concept this highlights the
need to raise awareness on
heavy infection in order to set up
a inadequate screening in all
individuals
at risk to develop severe complications
such as individuals with an underlying
chronic liver
disease there's also the evidence
that the outcome of hev infection
can depend on hev genotypes
in particular genotype 1 and 2
are usually considered more violent
than genotype 3 and 4 and are associated
with the most severe forms of epocities
a category of individuals deserving
particular attention
is represented by pregnant women
an infection sustained by genotype
one in pregnant women is associated
with a 30 percent risk to develop
advanced hepatitis hepatitis
failure furthermore infection by
genotype 1 has been associated with the
onset of
severe placental diseases
and these severe clinical manifestations
are typical of genotype 1 and
have not been observed for other
genotypes such
as genotype 3
in particular this is an interest in
studying
ana comparing the efficiency of
hev replication in particular
of replication of genotype 1 and
3 at the maternal fetal interface
represented by the decidua and placinta
tissues this study shows that
a genotype one is characterized
by a higher efficiency of
hev over replication and
can invade the more efficiently
the decidua and the placenta then
genotype
3. furthermore compared to genotype
3 genotype 1 is associated
with an higher amount of apoptotic cells
and it is also associated with a higher
secretion of
pro-inflammatory cytokines
these results have been confirmed also
in this study again supporting
reinforcing
the pathogenetic role of genotype 1
in the setting of pregnant women
hiv infection is
usually considered a self-limiting
infection however there's strong
evidence that hev can also
establish a chronic infection in
particular in the setting
of immune suppressed individuals
and this is a typical feature of
genotype 3 chronic hev
infection is defined as the persistence
of hev
rna in serum or in the stool
for longer periods in particular for
more than
three or six months
chronic infection can be asymptomatic
however there's a 10 percent of the
individuals
developing chronic hev infection
who rapidly progress towards cirrhosis
that can lead to patients death is if
not
properly treated the risk
to acquire chronic hev infection
depends on different factors first of
all
the amount of immune suppression
in particular it has been shown
that transplantation is associated
with the highest risk to acquire
chronic infection in this setting we
have the risk
of 50 60 of
chronicity in patients with
hematological or rheumatological
diseases
the risk to develop a chronic infection
is around 30 percent furthermore
chronic infection has been also observed
in people living with hiv here
the risk of chronicity depends on the
levels of the cd4
t cell count even if it has been shown
that
chronic infection can persist even after
the immunological
recovery driven by antiretroviral
treatment
another factor that can modulate
the risk to establish chronic hev
infection is represented by the type of
immune suppression in particular
it has been shown that the use of
tacrolimus
is associated with a higher risk
to develop a chronic infection than
cyclosporine a in vitro studies
have also shown that sculpting urine
inhibitors are characterized by a
direct pro viral activity so they can
directly stimulate hev replication
conversely mycophenolic acid
can suppress the replication of the
virus
and overall these suggest the
possibility to
modulate the choice of immune
suppressive
agents in the setting of organ
recipients
undergoing an hev infection
finally the risk to establish chronic
infection can also depend on viral
factors
and in particular on the extent of hev
genetic variability has shown
in this study in particular the study
shows that
patients developing chronic infection
are characterized by a higher degree of
genetic
variability at the time of acute
infection
implying the emergence of immune escape
mutations that could favor the
persistence
of a viral replication in the setting of
a weakened immune responses
is hev only a matter of the liver
as i told you before of course heb is an
apostotropic
virus however there's a strong evidence
that hev can be associated
with a large variety of extropathic
clinical manifestations and in
particular the most
common extrapolitic clinical
manifestations
are neurological disorders hematological
disorders
or kidney injuries the extratastic
clinical manifestations can be due to a
cross-reactive
immune response to hev
however they can also be caused by
a direct viral replication in tissues
other than the liver indeed different
studies have found have detected the
intermediate
of the viral replication in different
tissues such as the brain kidney spleen
small intestine and as we discussed
before
in placenta let's focus on
neurological disorder in particular the
onset of neurological disorders
have observed in the setting of
infection sustained
by genotype 3 in europe or
by genotype 1 in asia neurological
disorders usually emerge in immune
competent
individuals however they have been
observed
also in the setting of immune suppressed
patients developing a chronic infection
most importantly neurological disorders
can be the only symptoms associated with
hev infection so they can
emerge even in complete absence of
liver symptoms becoming the dominating
symptom associated with hev
infection and this has an important
implication
for a proper identification of
individuals
candidate to hev screening
this study has also
found equality species
compartmentalization
again as we have discussed before
testing
suggesting that genetic viral species
circulating detected in the brain
are genetically being sticked from those
observed
in the bloodstream suggesting the
emergence
the selection of neurotropic
variants we have discussed
during the presentation different
categories of individuals that are at
risk to develop
severe complications associated with hev
infection underlying the importance
to have effective drugs to
treat hev however
so far there are no approved drugs
for the treatment of hev infection
and the patients are usually treated
with
broad spectrum agents represented by
peg interferon or rabbi vary
however these drugs are not indicated in
pregnant
women for this reason the scientific
community is investigating novel
compounds
for instance sofasbuvir is an inhibitor
of a viral polymerase
it is already approved for the treatment
of
epacity's c virus so false believer has
been tested
in immune suppress the patients
developing chronic
infection and not responding to
rabbi viren it has been shown that
sophosphere can reduce viral load
can reduce the extent of hev
replication however it cannot cause
the clearance of the virus other
compounds
are under investigation targeting viral
polymerase but also
viral helicase and in particular
these compounds seem to have
a promising efficacy particularly when
they are combined
with immunomodulants such as interferon
lambda
supporting that in the next future
presumably
the approach to treat hev infection
can be represented by a combination
of an antiviral plus an immune modular
agent so in conclusion hev
can be acquired by a large variety of
roots and so this fuels the transmission
of hev
infection worldwide hev
can be associated with the severe forms
of hepatitis
in particular the categories of
individuals that are at
risk to develop these severe forms of
hepatitis
are pregnant women in which we have a 30
percent
risk to have an acute hepatic
failure but also in the patients with
an underlying chronic liver disease
as we have told before in this
setting hev related acuton chronic
liver failure is often unrecognized
or misdiagnosed finally
hev can establish a chronic infection
in the setting of immune suppressed
patients and this chronic infection
has been associated with an increased
risk
to develop cirrhosis so overall findings
highlight
the importance to raise awareness on hev
and thus to promote an adequate
screening in
all individuals that risk to acquire heb
infection in particular those
that are at risk to develop severe
clinical manifestations
i thank you for your attention and
now i can go over to romina's
presentation
thank you valentina and thank you to the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
to talk about
the epidemiological and the
diagnostic aspect related to hepatitis
e
hepatitis virus is the most common cause
of acute viral hepatitis worldwide
and according to this who funded
modeling study
each year 20 million people are
estimated to be infected with
heb with 3 million of symptomatic cases
70 000 of deaths and 3 000
still birth
despite this huge number the global
burden
of hepatitis e as well as related
morbidity and mortality is likely to be
significantly
underreported mostly due to
limited spread of diagnosis screening
and the positivity of national
surveillance programs
for hepatitis infection
and according to this recent
meta-analysis that
included the study of heb
prevalence collecting data from 75
countries of the six continents there is
an estimation that
up to 1 billion people worldwide
have been infected with hepatitis
in the past this means that
hiv infection has
been reported in 1 8 of global
population
and 100 million people
is experiencing a recent or ongoing
hepatitis infection always according to
these methodologies
the thorough prevalence of the infection
ranges from
six percent in oceania up to
21 percent in african counts significant
content
in this the epidemiology of a vitatisee
varies greatly by geographic location
and a two-sided epidemiological scenario
is reported
with ale endemic countries mostly
concentrating developing ward
where the infection of hepatitis c
causes more than 25 percent
of infection on a and not b
and endemic countries with less sporadic
outbreaks inhibited symmetry of
a hepatitis infection is concentrating
mainly
in developing countries mostly in africa
south east asia and latin america
in this region there are large and
frequent
outbreaks that affect several dozens of
people
and are mainly related to the
consumption of drinking water
contaminated with fetal material
however in the left they say there is
increasing
evidence of frequent locally acquired
hepatitis infection
also in several developed countries
almost the entire europe north and south
america
and japan in this region
there are several aspects related mostly
to zoonotic transmission
through the consumption of uncooked
undercooked meat
and blood transfusion and organ
transplant are also reported as
minor source of contagion in this area
thanks to the introduction of robust
serological
molecular assay now we know that
hepatitis e
is an emerging viral infection also in
industrialized countries
with hot spots of infection revealed
particularly in some european countries
as germany
netherlands france and switzerland
and this datum is in line with
the acdc report that
shows a tenfold increase of the
infection
cases in europe between 25
and 2015 with a market rise
in the last five years and this evidence
together
with the uh reporting that all eighty
percent of cases are mainly
diagnosed in germany france and uk where
a well-established surveillance of hiv
is established highlights the
fact that hepatitis is a public head
concern
also in europe and claims the need to
implement the surveillance for the virus
and let's move the diagnostic aspect of
hepatitis e
these graphs resume the kinetics of the
egnoxy marker during
hepatitis e acute infection
rna can bend can be detected in blue
blood on stool
three week weeks for infection and
the varying and bala shedding in physics
last approximately four six weeks
and around the time of clinical onset
also biochemical liver marker become
elevated
and the antibodies against the varus
start to appear
igm first followed by
igg igm are
short-lived and last three four months
differently igg continued to rise
during the comparison period and remains
detectable also for years and probably
according to
more recent studies for lifetime
and this is an overview of the panel
of the gnostic assay available for
hepatitis e immune cells detecting
igm are the most commonly employed
methods for diagnosis a recent hepatitis
e
infection this state targets
immunodominant part of
earth 2 and r3 proteins and an
increase in sensitivity and specificity
was reported in
new generation assays respect to the
past
the detection of igg with
igm negativity reflects a past
infection with hepatitis e
and this test is particularly useful for
assessing the ferro prevalence of the
infection
and to establish a vaccine response
recently some companies have also
launched
quantitative essays to evaluate the
levels
of antibodies class g
these levels can be particularly useful
for patient monitoring during
infection indeed it is known that
peaks of this antibody predict
convolution and recovery
and a study published on the
international journal of infected
disease this year
also showed that their liver inversely
and strongly correlates
with viral load suggesting the potential
utility of
egg quantitative for estimating and
predicting violent clearance
furthermore igg quantification
is also useful for predicting
reactivation or
infection cases indeed according
to recent study low antibodies title
is not protective against infection
this has been demonstrated particularly
in the setting of solid organ
recipients and further studies are
needed to better assess this
aspect in the setting of
immunocompetence and
more competent patients
similarly quantifying the
igg is also useful to determine the
protective antibody level
after vaccination this is a matter of t
to be determined
even if some studies suggest that
a liver above one who unit ml
could be protected against infection
after vaccination
recently some studies have also assessed
the potential utility of
ability index in determining
and in diagnosis discriminating
inaccurate
versus the past infection
ability tests estimate the binding
affinity between the antibody and the
antigen
that is typically whisked in the early
stage of infection
and increasing the later phase
does a strong
inability below 40 percent is a strong
indication of acute infection
why while they level above 60
can indicate past infection
however there are some limitations
primarily david index below
between 40 and 60 percent
falls in a gray area that is difficult
to interpret
furthermore there are no commercially
available large scale
essay for a visibility determination
until now
if serology is surely the mainstay
for diagnosis of avatar disease in this
in the setting of immunocomponent
patients
the situation is quite different in
immunocompromised
patients in these in these cases
is crucial the role of determining their
levels of
hiv rna
immunocompromised testing negative for
igm
should indeed be tested also for rna
in this positive result for rna or
egm is confirmatory of reasoned
and active infection but negative
results for
both marker are required to exclude an
hiv
infection rna
is is also used to identify chronic
hepatitis e
and this defecting of chronic hepatitis
rna levels
it's also used to evaluate the response
of patients
to the intensification of immune
suppressive therapy
or to antiviral therapy
lastly recently in the landscape of
hev diagnostic emerge another marker
that is represented by
hepatitis e capsid antigen
recently proposed for the diagnosis of
acute and chronic infection
however despite an improved sensitivity
of usa
for their determination respect to older
version
it remains less sensitive respect
to hiv rna
in spite of this suboptimal sensitivity
there is a good correlation between the
antigen
and rna levels and these render this
marker a potential cost-effective
alternative
real-time pcr particularly for resource
limited settings
and this is the diagnostic algorithm for
achieving fashion recommended by the
european
association for the study of the liver
that recommends
to use a combinatory approach
based on both serology and molecular
testing to diagnose
hepatitis e and rna
is particularly useful to diagnose both
acute and chronic infection in the
setting of immune compromision
how to interpret this marker always
according to easel guidelines acute
infection can be diagnosed by detection
of antibodies
positivity to igm and rising level
of igg a nice infection can also be
diagnosed on the basis of positive into
rna
or antigen together with serology
or alone for determination a chronic
infection
the detection of rna or antigen for a
peter
higher than tremonts is crucial
infection
who should be screened and who should be
test for
hev infection according to his ego line
all patients with biochemical evidence
of hepatitis
should be test for hepatitis e
as part of first line biological
investigation also patient with
other relevant as the compensatory liver
disease
neurological trophy guillain-barre
syndrome
and encephalitis should also be tests
for hepatitis e
irrespective of alt
results
and in particular acute hepatitis c
is an important differential diagnosis
in cases of suspected drug induced liver
injury
and this is particularly true in all
people
where the assumption of multiple
medications
can less can lead to a misdiagnosis
of hepatitis e confused with
liver injury induced by drugs
what about blood safety and hepatitis
e
as discussed by valentina hepatitis e
can also be transmitted by
blood transfusions and the cerebral
prevalence
of hepatitis e among robot donors is
quite high in several european countries
and in asia
but of notes it's even more important to
remark
that that there is a relevant rate
of aramic donors that was found not only
in asia and african areas but also in
many
european countries these
allies and support they need to consider
routine screening
for hepatitis e in blood bones
either guideline at this regard
recommend that
all patients with abnormal liver
functionality
test after receiving blood products
should be tested
for hepatitis e and
regarding the screening is a gel line
suggests to evaluate the screening of
blood donors
also after a more
refined study of risk assessment
and cost effectiveness to understand the
royal
variability of this approach
and the picture of skinny study ranges
for birth supply
is very multi-phased with some countries
opting for a universal screening of
all blood donors as ireland uk
netherlands and japan
while other countries prefer a selective
screening
restricted to patients that have a high
risk of
developing complications as france
austria and luxembourg also about
there is debate about the screening
strategy to use
because they some laboratory prefer
an individual donation
screening while others prefer
to pull together serum for
screening purpose
let's move to the screening of organ
donors
hepatitis a acute infection in organ
transplantation
is now known to be less rare than
previously
estimated and these methanolis
showed that the pooled estimated
prevalence of acute infection in
recipients of organ on solid organ
is about four percent
however most studies do not does not
discriminate
between transmitted and the novel
infection
mostly due to the lack of information
related to donors
this french study was the first to show
evidence of transmission of hepatitis e
after
kidney transplantation from a donor that
resulted positive both for serology
and for varimia before
transplantation on this basis
his auto suggests to consider a
systematic screening of donors
both by hav rna and by
hiv serology
today uk defined the first guideline
for hepatitis in solid organ
transplantation
that recommend a screening strategy for
hiv
for all organ donors
and this recommendation is also
shared by the spanish society of
infectious diseases and clinical
microbiology
however the detection of hiv buremia
in a donor is not a criteria to exclude
the nation but this will inform the
management of the patient after tough
plantation
let's finish with the prevention of
hepatitis e
prevention is surely the most effective
approach
against the disease and at population
levels transmission can be reduced
mainly by maintaining quality standards
for public water
establishing proper system for human
species
and strengthening the screening in
animals addressed to human feeding
on individual levels infection risks can
reduce by maintaining
adequate hygienic practice by a body
consumption or water
of an impurity particularly endemic
setting
and by limiting consumption of uncooked
and undercooked meats
from pigs wild boar and deer
today there is also a vaccine that is
available
it was developed by chinese company and
i approved by chinese
food and drug administration in the end
of 2011 and today
however it is still licensed only for
china the vaccine is a recombinant one
based on a portion of the capsic
protein derived from genotype 1
hepatitis e and the dimerization of
distortion
led to a protruding domain of the native
captive protein that is responsible for
eliciting neutralizing antibodies
clinical data are really promising and
show that the efficacy of the vaccine is
very high 97 percent
in both adults and
young people and however
double chew calls for further study in
order to evaluate the safety and the
effectiveness of this vaccine in
vulnerable
population as pregnant women or immune
suppressed
patients
future challenges against hepatitis
relies in improving
the strategy to fight the infection
in terms of a better prevention
by extending vaccination and by by
promoting
safer hygiene measures and improve
animal derived food control terms
of optimization of screening
by enlarging the diagnostic availability
and by spreading the screening campaigns
worldwide and lastly it's really
important to focus on treatment
in order to individuate new
approaches for antiviral therapy
only addressing these three relevant
topics
with permits to obtain the final aim
to reduce the burden of the disease
related to hepatitis e virus around the
world
thank you for your attention
thank you dr stitcher and dr cell pv for
your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
can the use of riboviron be associated
with the emergence of drug resistance
thank you so much for these interesting
questions
yes the use of rabbi varin can be
associated
with the emergence of a drug resistance
in particular so far a mutation has been
identified
this is the one type g 1634
r mutation in viral polymerase
in vitro studies have found that this
mutation
can enhance hev replication
during a treatment in presence of the
drugs
and in vivo have found that
this mutation can emerge and contribute
to
biological failure
thank you dr switzer our next question
is
which is the zero prevalence and the
outcome of atv infection in hiv-infected
patients
thank you so much this is another
interesting
question in particular the zero
prevalence of
hev infection in people living with hiv
varies worldwide it has been estimated
that
it is particularly high in africa and
in asia in which we can have a
zero prevalence of around 30 percent
in europe and in the americas we can
have a zero prevalence
of around the five and ten percent
the outcome of hev infection in people
living with hiv
is a super impossible to that observe
in individuals who are not infected
by hiv however as we have
discussed before we have a risk
to develop a persistent a chronic hev
infection in people living with hiv
and this risk can depend on the levels
of the cd4 t cell count
interestingly it has been shown that
people living with hiv can be at risk
of hev ray infection
hev reinfection that can be uh diagnosed
has the concomitant detection
concomitant positivity to
iggs against hev and
um positivity to he
rna thank you for these
questions all right thanks again dr
svitcher
we have another question is there
evidence of hev
reinfection thank you for the question
and according to a recent study
performing animal models
the risk of infection is quite high in
particular in this study on radius
macaques
30 of animals experience through
infection
an infection that correlated with lower
ability index and lower size
of antibodies the resin pledge scale
study in china suggests that
roughly 20 percent of symptomatic
infection in immunocomplained
individuals
is probably caused by infection and
also in this case their infection risk
correlated
with lower title of antibodies
however further studies are necessary to
define
the specific categor of antibodies that
is capable to prevent
their infection
thank you dr salpini our next question
is
is the available is the available
vaccine active against
all hev genotypes the vaccine
was built on the capsid protein derived
from genotype
1 and today some most clinical studies
were conducted
in china and the results showed that the
vaccine has high
efficacy against genotypes 1 and 4
suggesting a potential cross genotype
activity
this cross genotype activity is also
confirmed by a recent
immunological study published in natural
communication
showed that vaccine-induced antibodies
has a high degree of coral diversity and
recognize
multiple antigenic sites and cross-react
with all other genotypes however to date
there are no clinical data on the
efficacy of the vaccination
against genotype 2 and 3
the more common genotype among developed
countries
looks like that's all we have time for
today thank you again dr svitcher and dr
salpini for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor diathoran for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye